Michael Jordan told me after they swept  us before you succeed you must first  learn to fail and I just got tired of  failing so one time we got swept by the  Spurs and I went in the bathroom and I  ripped up all the toilets all the  urinals there was [ __ ] flying everywhere  and Jerry West came in there and he  grabbed me you're strong as hell too and  he put me up against me I calm down it's  like I'm trying to lose he's like you're  gonna get it done I went to the finals  eight times in a row before I won and  lost and like my soul just left my body  I was like what I'm like hold on say  that again he's like yeah I went there  eight times you know we could never beat  the Celtics so I didn't feel as bad but  I still had them hunger and I was like  okay not only am I going to do it for me  I'm gonna do it for YouTube Mr West